vamos votar de todos como vão haver pelo
meu sotaque eo no cic na madeira neste
nos açores na história neste aqui se ea
minha história começa na cidade de angra
do heroísmo na ilha terceira mais
propriamente na freguesia de são pedro
foi lá que iniciei o meu pai era uma
pessoa durante mais uma pessoa que
sempre achou muito por mim eu era aquela
criança que chegava a casa com o teste
96 por cento a matemática estava o meu
pai todo contente meu pai dava pra mim
assim como os outros quatros e ir mais
além
não há nada que uma criança queira mais
do que a aprovação dos pais
portanto isto obrigou a fazer mais para
desviar de uma frase que eu gostava
muito que é o teu standard tem que ser a
influência escolher mal continua a ser
muito bom escolher muito mal continua a
ser bom
então eu comecei assim não ser vender
qualquer coisa não podia ver as flores
que a minha mãe tinha no quintal poder
comprar pastilhas cidade no primeiro
andar da minha casa viverem os meus avós
de uma tia avó consumo da casa mas eu
aprendi a fazer casas por vender então
comecei a vender hoje sim isso na altura
era fantástica porque não tinha que
pegar um problema então meu futuro no
mérito ou familiares quando o cliente é
muito muito bom na praia
trinta por uma linha quando fui para a
faculdade saídos das hoje fui viver para
lisboa para o acumulado a primeira vez
que eu me apercebi que tudo isto que eu
tinha foi estas aventuras completamente
sem estrutura fase isto um defendia o
nome disto era em
links terá uma temática existiam
milhares de pessoas como eu milhares de
artigos e livros escritos sobre isto e
eu entrei tanto na que o tema
estreitando eu nunca fui confessa o
típico macau mas na faculdade as coisas
acabaram por ser muito bom porque acha
quando nós fazemos aquilo que gostamos
não de custa fazer mais do que seria
normal e como é natural os resultados
também vai em cima do normal
então não é tudo isto com seu organizar
conferências de empreendorismo workshops
de empreendorismo e foi nessa altura que
entrou uma coisa chamada crise em
portugal
chris troika fmi estamos nessa fase é
possível montar toda a gente farta de
palavras bonitas e vocês conteúdo está
toda a gente for mal em gravatá vá a
falar em programas na televisão sobre os
índices macroeconômicos
mas a verdade é que o dia a dia nós
estávamos a ter dificuldades escolhas
não melhoravam conseps verão que as
pessoas em outras desembolso que o homem
vem do bolso o dinheiro ainda faça que o
bolo mas é fácil montar de uma sã
incrível site do facebook estão mais
qualquer coisa vai dar não vamos ficar
parados não é assim tão complicado então
foi eu vou dar uma volta ao mundo
sozinho encheu as costas durante um ano
e rotatórias pessoas que fizeram
acontecer nos quatro cantos do mundo
você clicar vale falar com milionários
mas também com a índia ea tanzânia
pois vou trazer esta história volta a
portugal e com isso vão inspirar as
pessoas a fazerem mais tranqüilidade
posso dizer quando lembra ele estava em
casa sentado no sofá como foi lembrando
que fez que volta ao mundo e tal depois
comecei a perceber que tinha 10 os meus
pais também não sou rico até então tinha
que fazer alguma coisa e começar de fato
de pur de facto para vender as coisas
que tinha para vender as coisas todas
que tinha e não tinha cartas nem casas
por vender mas tenho uma boa história
chan e uma camisola número 10 do salve
quando estava no benfica uma camisa de
jogo
ele custa falar nisso mas é pra vocês
verem o grau de comprometimento que
estava com o projeto
vendi tudo obviamente não era suficiente
e durante dois anos que foi o tempo de
preparação todo o projeto eu apresentei
esta loucura para inspirar o país a 97
empresas 97 destas 97 ou 7 disseram que
sim
o primeiro sim foi a número 53 cada vez
que ia para casa com um negócio com as
lágrimas nos olhos porque também o apoio
de quem estava à minha volta dos meus
pais que moram na ilha terceira em angra
não era propriamente chegou a fazer uma
volta ao mundo olha dá duas guardam
como é normal nós temos de nós quando
estamos a fazer uma coisa nova nós
partilhamos com quem está próximo e que
lhes é próximo por alguma tensão talvez
puxados para trás e nós isso é muito
complicado estatura foi difícil para mim
porque eu tenho que ter em dia pra mim
vamos fechar em frente e puxados em
frente ilhéus mas então vende as coisas
todas pedir patrocínios
mesmo assim tinha talvez 30 a 40 por
cento menos do orçamento que eu achava
que precisava mas como tem o curso de
gestão olha para o excel com muita
atenção e vi que e vi que eu tinha
dinheiro para fazer uma volta ao mundo
eu tinha dinheiro para começar em
portugal passar para as pessoas voltarem
a portugal não tinha dinheiro era pra
comer nem dormir mas falta muito tinha
então sem a minha mãe saber eu pensei ao
passivo na mesma e amanhã hoje temos
aqui algumas mães natal a minha mãe
fazia uma coisa incrível
a minha mãe ia para o facebook que acha
que as doenças que andavam lá ele
mandava andré vez na tanzânia um grupo
de xiitas duas com duas cabeças mãe vai
acontecer
adaptei a viagem toda não tinha dinheiro
todo em o toys procurar grupos causa
está a fim de terminar rua
administrações de combóio estações de
autocarros investiu material xpto eram
coisas que já tinha em casa viram
disseram que vão sacar cama quando vi o
quanto é que custava 1 600 euros porque
não sabíamos de tudo e mais alguma coisa
foi com sá cama 99 campanha não seria o
pai da minha casa e frio mas aprendi com
isso que nunca muito forte na vida
também ceifada espera daquela promoção
só falta mais isto é só juntar mais um
campo em áreas são mais do que o país
não há um dia que tem que dar um murro
na mesa e temos que andar pra frente e
nunca muito foi feito mas é sempre muito
foi pra começar e eu pensei agora e fui
pai durante um ano e 23 países mais de
127 mil quilômetros emprestar pessoas
que fizeram acontecer
cingapura brasil índia e na tailândia
auxilia a austrália tanzânia
aquelas coisas que vemos nas revistas o
país humilde da ilha terceira
andré luis na frente de são paulo e só
de ver o mundo caísse uma coisa que
nunca tinha passado pela cabeça nunca
achei que as tribos e vamos foi um
simples o incrível estive no facebook
andamos a tocar na índia e se vocês
pensam que aquilo não é nos filmes a que
josé malta lá é pior acredita
falei com os meus pais por ter uma idéia
durante a viagem falar com os meus pais
com calma nos cai três vezes aqui estou
eu com meu pai eu falar que com minha
mãe alitalia tia avó que fazem os cães
está tão em que estava o computador
quase momento com a cara do computador
no dia 3 de abril por exemplo o treino
paulo estava muito cansado e foi oster
lições mesmo cansado só querer tomar um
duche militar e um senhor de 51 frente
[Música]
então naquele dia eu entrava em 2031
é que um foi pior futuro e voltar e me
muita tom é coisa barata que nós
encontramos com o mundo que ajudou
esquerda viagem nunca mais ganhou nunca
vai ter um dia antes de as coisas
correram muito bem é portugal no coração
e rtp áfrica
aqui toda grandiosa tv facebook da
tanzânia quando você vê inclusive por
todo o lado
waris várias revistas em portugal e no
estrangeiro
o irão está assunto mil da ilha terceira
não foi foi um caso muito engraçado e
outro em portugal com 70 cêntimos no
café e traga algumas histórias pessoas
que eu consiga me inspiraram muito este
senhor é conhecido em portugal ricardo
teixeira e silva em lisboa no parque das
nações
estava a falar com ela e uma carta
contando que não estão com todas as suas
capacidades físicas
era uma pessoa muito ativa conquistas
anos estava numa praia brincar com os
amigos e no mergulho a coisa corra muito
mal eu ficar tetraplégica após como
disse na altura
quando nós ficamos tetraplégica que tudo
muda tudo começa de novo como jogamos no
computador como é que temos umas casas
as coisas mudam e como foi no novo eu
tenho que inventar isto agora são
palavras dela eu disse que tinha tudo
para ser um coitado em toda a minha vida
verá conta de subsídios do estado e de
ajudas e estrias e val mas se eles
contaram que o cartão aos 41 anos está à
frente cinco empresas é casado e tem um
filho quando ele pergunta como é que
isto é possível
eu olho pra mim mas em breve porque as
pessoas não fazem sabe por que as
pessoas querem ter as coisas sem terem
trabalho
isso não existe eu tento dos vossos
planos no dia a dia mas muitos problemas
física e faz e se eu faço vocês também
podem fazer vocês não fazem não querem
trabalhar não querem ir em frente
não há nada que se conquista na vida que
não têm trabalho foi isso que o mexilhão
esta história é muito especial e eu
trouxe aqui propositadamente esta
história porque o batismo do senhor como
cristiano ronaldo indiana vinha mas
agora acho que isso estava sendo traído
estava eu em délhi no meio daquela
confusão
toda esse senhor vem por trás de mim e
da montagu assim na cabeça olho pra trás
do estado
mesmo assim posso limpar os ouvidos de
um passo atrás disse canal e autismo do
fmi em portugal
olha eu sou o cristiano ronaldo a limpar
ou vídeos o melhor jogador do vídeo do
mundo abreu
agora vamos traçar técnica deu tanto
naquela hora ali está a colocar na
cotonete mágica o passado em um raio de
100 metros está sol hoje para toda a
sociedade
existem passou hoje e outra ficou então
talvez eu estava sim pressionar
começamos a conversa agora eu não deixar
que alguns impactos ouve a conversa e
perguntei porquê porque tudo resolvido e
eu disse olha tu volta eu comecei a
olhar uma pobreza extrema
andré tem uma mulher em casa tem dois
filhos em casa e tem que levar dinheiro
para casa para poder colocar comida na
mesa eu tenho que ser aqui há uma regra
que eu faço faço não fizeram como eu
aprendi que o elenco tem que ser tem que
ser limpo tem que ser tem muita força
esta é confesso que a minha história é
mais bacana eu estava no catania
todo mundo estava lá
o ministro da pasta que vocês vêem na
fotografia chamas queda e eu vivia no
bairro para casa e diz olha o monstro do
bairro sem qualquer tipo de problema meu
bom vamos lá
e pelo caminho para o céu ficou muito
contente porque o vinho do país do
campeonato então ficou assim com um
sorriso enorme eo apontada como é que
era como é que se vivem e vera eu deixo
olha que vieram da fantástica
são livros nós podemos dizer o que
queremos
o dow em que não era bem assim as casas
apesar de ser muito tumultuadas
o bom disso é que estou sempre com minha
família e dos meus amigos é incrível
vamos ter uma casa dela era terra um
gênero de um barco mas chapas assim mal
encostados e claramente piada
eu dizia muito contente aqui essa aula e
é um fato três lugares tudo parte do
estado há um desencanto que tem o quarto
era um colchão todo velho no chão tem 1
em sol e ouvir aquilo que se um
campeonato perguntado pela casa de banho
em lisboa o estado andré que não existem
casas bom em nós fazemos necessidades na
rua ou em sacos plásticos que nós
encontramos em que vera é isso é um
marco e sacos plásticos
é uma coisa impressionante
talvez como vocês já estava a ficar
truncado e ensinar e eu esta altura da
conversa devolve uma questão e pergunta
como é que é portugal como é que eu pois
do cristiano ronaldo com um sorriso
enorme e 161 qualquer coisa como ficou a
um país fantástico nós temos isso temos
aqui o tempo sol e apesar da crise
parece que as coisas estão agora a
melhorar
lembre se que o concelho viagem
estávamos em crise e queremos ter as
pessoas iam fazer mais
então eu pergunto isto e eu disse que
portugal a crise porque estava a passar
o que eu estou a ficar bonita casa cara
de um passado muito contente estou muito
preocupado
estamos em crise mas quantas vezes é que
vocês comem por semana
a última vez que eu fiz aqui em que vera
eu e minha família e com menos uma vez
por semana
como é que lá vocês tão bons aguentar
desde esse dia há uma questão que nunca
mais saiu da minha cabeça o que cage
está em crise e cada um terá sua
resposta eu andré leonardo nunca estive
chris nunca
não posso ir todos os dias como os meus
restaurantes ficaram com esparguete
confirmado em casa
isso não é mau e é incrível
todos os anos os próprios exóticos
ganhar o autocar rita por aí eu ainda
posso isto é mau e incrível eu aprendi
com o eu que nós perdemos muito tempo
que interessa com coisas que não
interessam a utilizar muitos dos meus
problemas pessoais e profissionais
agenda frente aos 79 80 anos
vamos todos para o mesmo jardim e tem
que aproveitar e as coisas que nos tiram
o foco de ali e valem zero
o sangue contra outra história porque lá
há dez dias 1º e 9 dias incríveis e troy
último dia era um domingo não tinha nada
pra fazer não deu entrevistas a pessoas
da casa também estava ruim disse que não
podia mostrar a cidade então a fonte
fomos conhecer a cidade
uma estamos cá para deixar as
coisas em casa porque está na rua é
perigoso de mulheres em casa a fonte
voltamos ao final do dia em uma roubada
porta roubaram tudo estava lá dentro
incluindo as minhas coisas
o quarto ficou assim tanto tudo aquilo
que eu tenha trabalhado durante dois
anos fora alguns pagamentos foram na
índia tinha por que motivo foi usada
para colocar o material roubado
a pessoa da casa encostou uma mala velha
eu coloquei o pouco que tinha ali no dia
seguinte já tinha comprado um vôo para a
índia
então estas da manhã estava no avião
fishkin da minha mala nova velha e e fui
para a índia e 6 uma e taiwan
seguro com escalas de gurgumba escala
mumbai délhi 30 horas que estava
extremamente preocupado foi como foi
quando serys e trabalhei tanto dois anos
mas tem justin está injusto como
aconteceu em 97 empresa esteja
genuinamente justo até nem de sair do
avião sempre no aeroporto para fazer a
ronda começa a funcionar as mãos começam
a sair pessoas a próximos pegaram formal
e vão embora e ao fim de 20 minutos a
pastora onde pára e hoje eu não via mala
olhei para o lado viu pessoas mal tinha
acabado de ficar literalmente só com a
roupa que tinha vestido no corpo estava
fisicamente sozinho e estava
emocionalmente sozinho
ai de mim que tenha tido a tentação de
jogar pra casa ea minha mãe nome
genérico aconteceu ela ia dizer se
existe uma visão
foi pra casa e não queria que isso
acontecesse
então tive cinco minutos genuinamente
sozinho sem saber quando e como haveria
de vir a 25 minutos de escuridão extrema
em uma sala escura chorar eu sou uma
pessoa muito positiva mas durante cinco
mil frança e acho que não há nada pior
do que não vai ter ninguém pra fazer
queixa à companhia aérea
fui ter com a família indiana que esta
eu ia ficar com os dois discos com os
duas semanas
dentro desta casa vi esta família e uma
galinha que na avaliação de ricardo
fonseca 11 rolei você certamente conhece
pelo menos o festival das cores que é
inspirado no rolê deram mais curta
pijama que não tinha roupa vestir e os
fizeram isso pra mim e mandou uma bela
todos os patrocinadores do projeto e
alguns deles só aumentaram quando em seu
patrocínio e o que fazer qualquer coisa
não era suficiente então fiz uma
campanha trote fanning
era tipo um salva o andré que investir
salvá-lo e william e paulo andré
as pessoas começaram a fazer donativos
estão aqui apenas algumas e o fim do
semana saindo com um orçamento mais
reduzido do que tinha no início e
consegui continuar em uma parede dela e
vi uma frase que se tornou um lema de
vida pra mim e nunca mais me esqueci que
qualquer que seja o problema faz parte
da solução
acho que nós temos demasiadas pessoas
que se foca no problema muito muito
poucos aqueles que falam as funções de
campo para frente por lutarem qual é
para si uma característica dessas
pessoas todas uma desses empreendedores
qual é aquela que todos os tem
é isto isso parece simples mas não é
toda a gente inclusive 70
a patroa tenta falar com a empresa já
falei com 33 mas vou quarta parte da
fauna funciona momento nas 14 97
quer saber mais está bem mas vou te
contar
ele vai ter que vender tudo tarde os
membros a imagem vou te contar
o pedido teve também mais apático roupa
que tem em casa
quem sabe mais e vou te contar sobre
2010 vai faltar
e temos que andar pra frente aprendi com
viagem com o difícil é diferente do
impossível
tetraplégica frente sempre presente o
senhor não parece que são muitíssimo
difícil não é impossível eu dar a volta
ao mundo para os meus amigos na ilha
terceira que usavam como e vai dar a
volta ao mundo mas olha a volta ao mundo
da volta primeira ilha que eu moro carro
mas foi feito aquilo que era impossível
na área são muito difícil e tenho
certeza que todos os que estão aqui têm
sonhos
quero vocês borboleta em ou não vocês
tensões coisas querem fazer isso
provavelmente nos parece impossível e
também pra mim que sou muito difícil
vai depender muito não das vossas
condições mas sim das vossas decisões
vocês vão ter que fazer acontecer
vocês vão ter que ser empreendedor não
no sentido da palavra tem que criar
negócios mas tem que andar para frente
ser empreendedor pra mim é esse é um
estilo de vida uma forma de estar é uma
atitude é pronto um problema arranjar
uma solução que andar pra frente e sim
nós temos ser empreendedores criando
negócios essa designação mais comum mas
tem que ser empreendedores trabalhando
para o outro e no nome técnico é vista
entre o empreendorismo ou ao limite
vamos empreender na nossa vida era lo
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
entendeu